hi everyone my name is Leticia Smith I'm
a data scientist at Teachers Pay
Teachers and today I'll be talking about
a personal project that I've been
working on to identify groups and
recipes that share similar ingredients
and I'll be sharing lessons that I've
learned along the way
so for background I got started on this
project at the beginning of the year
when I made the resolution to eat
healthier
however after checking out a few fad
diets in addition to recommended
nutrition guidelines I started to
recognize a common flaw and the weekly
eating guides one day you may have
lasagna for dinner the next day you have
curry each one of these dishes requires
a unique combination of ingredients that
will go to waste if not entirely used in
its dish now traditionally we solve this
problem by googling recipes that use
leftover ingredients however this
approach is reactive not proactive so I
want to see if I could leverage machine
learning in order to identify groups and
recipes with shared ingredients in order
to maximize the number or started to
maximize the number of Mills I can make
with the minimal amount of ingredients
with my research question defined it was
time for me to collect my data which is
where I learned my first lesson be kind
to your host which for me was all
recipes calm so I wanted to scrape and
analyze the ingredients found in dishes
on allrecipes.com
because it's arguably one of the most
popular recipe sites on the internet it
was founded in 1997 and what really made
this website distinct from a lot of
other recipe websites at the time is
that it had a strong community of users
who would leave reviews for the recipes
so if you look to the right or I guess
it's my right but your left is world's
best lasagna and that's the most popular
recipe in the main mill section of the
website and it has over 11,000 views so
this really helped to verify that these
recipes that I was looking at were
contain ingredients that were of high
quality and I focus specifically on
Maine Mills just because those are the
types of dishes that you would prepare
during mealtime or during dinner time
which is what I think that mill prep is
most important however before I had the
opportunity to scrape and analyze all
this data
I found myself siming the following text
message to a friend which I'll give you
all a moment to read
so no the site didn't know that I needed
the information for a project because I
would spring from this data when you
spread data your request to the site
travel at a faster rate when you then
when you're typing information into a
search bar and then I'm pressing a
button and because of that there are so
many requests that were going to the
server and the server wasn't having
enough time to respond so I just
basically like Fellig was under attack
and essentially stopped working so what
this experience taught me is that if you
do choose to scrape data from a website
you should check to see if the website
has a robots.txt file which contains
useful information such as having a
one-second crawl delay in between your
request just that the server has enough
time to respond the last time that I
scraped this website was in May of last
year at that point in time the website
had 14,000 recipes in the maintenance
section which was essentially a hundred
to 65 pages so after six hours I was
able to collect all of this data and it
was time for me to learn my second
lesson which made me comment to the
statisticians here which is data
analysis is like healthy eating garbage
in garbage out so like I said I really
wanted to identify the very best recipes
that this website had to offer so my
first step was taking a look at the the
average number of stars that the recipes
received so I have a histogram to show
you and if you look on the x-axis of
this histogram you'll see that it ranges
from 0 to 5 5 being the highest number
of stars that a recipe can receive and
the bin width for this histogram is 0.25
so if we look on the left from 0 to 0.25
approximately like a thousand recipes on
the side haven't been reviewed and one
thing that really surprised me I'm
looking at the data is that this
histogram for the most part has
a negative skew and the mean or the
average number of stars that a recipe
has received or their average star score
is four so on average recipes on this
site do you receive a favorable number
of reviews and I decided that I just
wanted to limit the analysis to recipes
that had received at least four and a
half stars that way I could at least say
that it was above average
I'm star score but the one problem with
that is I don't know if this is a recipe
like world's best lasagna that's
received like thousands and thousands of
reviews or if this is this recipe that's
been recently uploaded to the site made
me where there's only three or four
reviews so I also want to look at the
total number of reviews that recipes on
the site how do we see so I have two
steps to show you the first one
represents 90% of the recipes in the
main Mills section so this is all but
like the top 10% and the reason that I
put all these in the first histogram is
you'll see that the histogram has a
positive skew and the x-axis goes from 0
to 200 so anything over 200 just start
to be too low to view and the system
images that why I saved it for the
second one that I'll share and the bin
width here is 10 so if you look on the
x-axis between 0 and 10 you'll see that
I think it's like approximately 4500
recipes they've received zero to 10
reviews and then if you make your way
over on average recipes on the site have
received around 90 reviews and then for
my second histogram this is the top 10
percent of recipes then you'll see that
it ranges from 200 to almost 1,200 and
the bandwidth is 500 so if we look from
like 200 to 500 you'll see that around
200 to 500 recipes have received almost
1100 reviews so I've been looking at
this data I decided that I really want
to focus on the 130 region because
recipes that had received like around
130 reviews that sort of represents like
the top 15 percent of recipes on that
site
so to recap I wanted to look at recipes
that had at least poorness
4.5 stars 130 reviews with narrow at the
analysis - around 909 recipes so now
that I had the data I have a snapshot to
show you of what it looked like
so you'll see like it's not nicely
formatted but even though the format
doesn't look nice we as humans still
like you know what the recipes are slug
if you look at number four go down to
number two you'll see like the second
ingredient is vegetable oil very easy
for I came in to understand but that's
so easy for a computer to understand so
when you're processing text one of the
common approach is reading your text as
a bag of words so when you do that you
remove numbers and punctuation you
remove the endings of words like edy ing
that aren't as essential and you also
see AED ing ago sorry you also remove
software so these are words that are
common like the or a that don't really
I'm providing any additional information
about the context so that's what I did
with this data here to get a sense of
what these common food words were and
this is the word cloud that I got so you
can see g4 Gramps maybe you're lucky and
caml four milliliters and I know they're
like some work like chopped in there too
but I was looking for food words but I
was getting words related to units of
measurement also words related to food
preparation so I had to take a step back
and think like there are all of these
non-essential words here so I had two
approaches one of them was I could
create a corpus of stock words related
to recipes and extract those were or
remove those words beforehand and then
redo my word cloud but at best like that
would just take a lot of time trying to
get that corpus together but at worst I
could possibly like bias my results by
choosing which words are and are not
essential so instead I decided that I
really needed to identify like what were
the food words that way if any what the
food where its word then maybe I could
just look at a recipe and see if a
recipe has this food then like a check
so
I think I'd like to give is like
irregardless of whether or not a recipe
has like fresh green beans or canned
green beans or frozen green beans I just
really want to know that it had green
beans so what I've been doing is I
collected a list of food works so I got
this list from going to a variety of
sites that have food words so that I
could then create a matrix that I'll
show you here and what I did was I just
put the food words in the columns here
and then for each row I put a recipe and
if the recipe contained that food word
then I put a one in the column
indicating that the food was there and
that allow me to transfer this text via
that I had into a format that was easy
to feed into a computer and I have
another word cloud here and now you'll
see in my word cloud I actually have
food words and now that it had my data
clean it was time for me to learn my
final lesson which is to measure
carefully but season to taste so like I
said I really want to identify which
recipes were closest to one another
which implies that I needed to use a
distance metric and and are there are a
lot of different distance metrics and if
you use the wrong one then it will
produce misleading results so what I
have on the following slide is what my
data look like when I did not use the
proper distance metric I just use the
default metric which is Euclidean
distance so what I have up here is a
dendogram and it's a graphical
representation of hierarchical
clustering which is a bottom-up
clustering algorithm and for the view
who are unfamiliar with it the webinar
works is essentially each item which for
me where recipes are placed into a group
of its own and then the items are
incrementally paired based upon how
similar they are until they all end up
in an individual group which is really
difficult to see here because I use
Euclidian like I said which is the
default and wasn't really great for this
data but I played around and another
popular distance metric is Manhattan
distance I changed my distance metric
and now you start to see structure kind
of like
which you would see maybe for looking at
some sort of animal kingdom diagram and
so at this point I had measured properly
and now it was time for me to season to
taste so I like to think of statistics
as part science part art when you do
statistics there are assumptions and
there are sets that you need to make
sure that you take in order to to like
me whatever statistical standards for
the method that it is that you're using
and like for me that's hierarchical
clustering but I feel like the art
really comes with regards to the
interpretation of your results because
you do want to make sure that your
results makes sense and for a
hierarchical hierarchical clustering
like I said it's great because all of
your items do end up getting paired but
one downside is that they all end up and
it's similar because you'll see at the
top I have this line that's collecting
everything or started connecting
everything together but I was really
looking for individual groups and for
hierarchical clustering there are
different metrics that you can use to
identify like what are the best number
of divisions that I can make so I'll
just like stand over here I'll click to
show like you can cut at the top right
here across and then you can have seen
groups and add expenses late old like my
dad was the best represented by two
groups but that didn't work so I needed
to like dig a little bit deeper in the
data so maybe like d3 cuts one two three
like three divisions or four and then
whenever I made these divisions I would
then look at the groups to see like what
recipes are there what ingredients are
being used to see if the groups that I
had made sense and after playing around
with the data and digging into it I was
able to determine that my data could be
meaningfully represented and eleven
groups which I have here for you to see
so pan-asian
barbecue slow cooked poultry savory pie
marinade Italian tex-mex breadcrumbs of
veggies in shrimp and I let go into some
of those groups and a little bit but
just so you can see like if you look
down low enough you'll see how I made
the cuts to identify those eleven groups
all right so I'm after I had presented
some of these reasons I had people ask
me questions such as okay look you have
these eleven groups like
but what do those eleven groups actually
mean if I wanted to use them in my
day-to-day cooking so I thought of it
and then I have like one little bonus
tip which is don't be afraid to sample
along the way so after I got these
questions I like sort of did a thought
experiment in my head and I asked myself
what would happen if I were to randomly
select three recipes from a group and
after I randomly sampled those three
recipes I want to find the percentage of
the ingredients that are used in more
than one dish and what would happen if I
repeated that process 10,000 times so
I'm gonna show you what that looks like
in addition to showing you all what some
of the food words in the group were in
these groups in addition to some of the
different recipes okay
so I created the experiment with all the
recipes first so like I said pool three
see what percent are using more than one
recipe and how would you expect for 16
percent of the ingredients to be used in
more than one dish and then I have the
shrimp group here so to the my right
your left there's a word cloud some of
the common food words and then if we
look at the histogram we'll see that if
you were to randomly select three
recipes from the shrimp group you would
expect on average for 30 percent
36 percent of being gradients to be used
in more than one recipe yeah more than
one dish and here's an example of some
of the recipes that are in that group
okay Nexus is breadcrumb group and to
provide some context the breadcrumb
group is really for recipes where either
you're making like some type of patty or
maybe you're frying something which is
why the breadcrumbs were so prominent
along with other foods such as edge that
you use for that process and here are
some of the examples of the recipes
Nexus the chicken broth break seeking
look and here are some examples
next is the barbecue group
and the last one that I show us the
pan-asian group sometimes was pretty
cool just because of that commonality of
soy sauce really helped to unite those
recipes together all right so next step
I thought this is like a really cool
project just because I felt like I was
able to identify the groups of recipes
that shared similar ingredients without
having to pre-specify foods up front one
thing that I will say though is that
some of these groups are like kind of
intuitive friends like if I want to make
tex-mex maybe I like don't necessarily
have to choose specific ones from that
text message but I start to realized
that either the groups are
representative of cuisines but also some
of the proteins played a very heavy role
in identifying those groups so since
some of them have been intuitive I think
in the future maybe trying to play
around with maybe removing some of those
protein or to see like what type of
groups do I then get or sometimes the
words like salt are common throughout
the groups to like well with my groups
like if I look like if I were to remove
some of those core staples so in
conclusion when clicking up statistics
remember to be kind to your host garbage
in garbage out and to measure carefully
but to season to taste I think and thank
you
you